I'm so excited to make your acquaintance.
I'm so excited to make yours
and thank you so much for having me.
I am like such a huge fan of yours
and always have been, so thank you so much.
Oh my goodness, I'm such a fan of yours
and I have to tell you, when I read the way you speak
you're so eloquent and I've read a lot
about how you navigate social media
and you come from a family that we all know,
but you even said, "I'd rather be boring and private
than put my whole life out there."
How did you become so wise and know to do that?
Well, thank you.
That's really sweet of you to say.
I think that, you know, the, the value
of privacy is something that's like been instilled
in me from, from an early age and something that, you know
growing up in a family like I did was always, you know
something that was, I always learned the importance of
of privacy and, and, you know, valuing that
and keeping things just for yourself.
And so that's something that I've carried on
into my own career, and that's really important to me.
And you're someone who's out there,
you have millions of followers, you're, you know
becoming this huge film star, this, you know
model out there.
You are literally the Chanel girl and have been for years
which is so cool because your mom was a Chanel woman.
I know, I know it's like the best.
I think it's all about, you know, I think no part of it
is about not enjoying the fun that can come from that
because obviously like, you know the main thing is
that I'm just so grateful to do something that I love to do.
And I really recognize the privilege
in waking up and being able to love my job
because I know that that's not true for everybody.
And so I'm really grateful for that and,
whether that's acting or working with Chanel, you know
these are all things that mean a lot to me.
And so I think it's just
about balancing that with also wanting to, you know
keep other things private and enjoy other parts of life.
Well, that's what I related to is
'cause I put myself out there and yet I'm very protective
of my kids and it can seem sort of schizophrenic
and confusing and nobody's right, and nobody's wrong.
It's just these choices
and I think you have to have a level of self-awareness
and life experience to make those decisions.
And I really applaud yours because you're right.
You are having fun with that.
Totally, totally and I,
and there's so much fun to be had you know,
not even in this job, but just in life, you know
it's good to, you know, find the good in everything
and that puppy on your lap is so cute.
I can't stop looking at him.
He's breaking my heart.
It's, it's national adopt a pet day
and we have this whole pen of puppies and kitties.
And it's just amazing how like soothing,
you have a bulldog, right?
Or a French bulldog?
I do.
I have an English bulldog and I have a little cat as well.
And they're both not with me today.
They're there in LA.
I'm actually going to them soon, hopefully
but you've got me extra missing my pets today, for sure.
Oh well, here, these are all named
after "Bridgerton" characters.
Have you watched "Bridgerton"?
I have not gotten to it yet, but I really,
it's really on my list.
I really need to.
I must say, Miss Depp run, don't walk.
It's so good.
I really, really, really, oh, this is Brimsley Bridgerton.
Oh.
I love a fancy name on a pet.
Okay.
I also, I'm really excited to talk to you about Voyagers.
I love this director.
I really thought that the film "Limitless" stood out.
It's so highly respected
and he is a real visionary and this film is no exception.
So tell me if I'm getting this right
because there are basically people bred
and born to not be on earth
and to live in a different atmosphere
and be sort of given a lifestyle
that will make them act a certain way,
but human nature is human nature.
Yes, that feels, that feels quite accurate.
Basically they have been born and bred for this mission.
They've bred these kids and then when we meet them again,
they're like 16, 17 and they basically discover
that they've been taking the blue,
which is this kind of sedative basically,
that's made to make sure that they don't,
that their hormones aren't kind of like running wild and
and that they basically stay on track
and that they stay these kinds
of little work machines for the mission.
And then, you know, once that fact is discovered
and you know, people stop taking it and stuff,
things kind of all chaos kind of ensues after that.
I just love this.
and you are so compelling and so beautiful and so cool.
And I can't wait to see you at the forefront
of this really interesting movie.
Thank you so much.
Well, that's so sweet and same to you,
you are such a sunny, positive, wonderful energy,
and it was so lovely to meet you
and speak to you and see your face.
It was so lovely to meet you.
Lily Rose Depp Voyagers is in theaters today!
And it's so amazing, go watch it,
think, feel and get rockets.
(upbeat music)